the reddit revolt has cost
short sellers institutional investors
more than
70 billion dollars so far this year
this year hasn't been going on for very
long uh this all part of the gamestop
madness the dogecoin madness
and most importantly of all for our
politics
as a result of the established platforms
the
big institutions pushing back we'll get
into it i'm michael knowles it's the
michael knowles show
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from kerbal
air force who says i have dubbed this
outsider trading
that's the thing you know when we talk
about insider trading we say people who
have
sort of secret knowledge that they
shouldn't have and they make money it's
it's illegitimate
well there's another kind of insider
trading it's people who are on the
inside who are in the
giant financial institutions who are
cozy with the regulators
who are cozy with the tech apps that are
the broker dealers that allow you to
make these trades
and then there are the outsiders these
rap scallions on reddit
and other retail investors who when they
try to
use the same strategies that the
institutional investors do
they get completely shut out can't have
those peasants making
too much money at all it just reminds us
when we see how rigged
so many of these systems are you got to
protect your data online you've got to
get
express vpn big tech companies have a
ton of power in our country today
and as private entities they can operate
pretty much as they choose
protect your personal data from big tech
with the vpn i trust for my online
protection
expressvpn when i use expressvpn my
connection gets
routed through their secure encrypted
servers
so that these companies can't see my ip
address at all
the best part is that you don't need to
be tech savvy at all to use expressvpn
just download the app on your phone or
computer you tap one button
you are protected visit expressvpn.com
michael
to get three extra months free on a one
year package i know what you're thinking
you're thinking no one's after my data
it doesn't matter listen if you're
listening to this show right now
someone tells me you go to some dodgy
sites on the internet you know you pull
up that incognito window
you go to places like dailywire.com head
on over protect yourself exp
or essvpn.com michael to get
three extra months for free that is
expressvpn.com
michael great way to protect your data
head on over to
expressvpn
we we went into some detail on what was
going on
in the markets yesterday because what's
going on in the markets
more so than usual is reflecting what's
been going on in our politics
not just for the last two months but for
the last four years
five years what happened yesterday
is a bunch of people on reddit
gathered together they saw that a big
hedge fund had a massive short position
on
gamestop which is not a valuable company
in and of itself
but the the institutional investor had
this short position meaning they were
betting against the stock
so all these reddit guys went in and put
their money
on game stock game stop rather game stop
stock
and that drove the price up as the price
went up the people with the short
positions have to shell out more and
more money
and the the premise of these redditors
is they were willing to remain
completely insane
longer than the financial institutions
could remain
solvent and this would result in them
making a bunch of money
so it was all going according to plan
gamestop hit up to i think 460 dollars
there were other
not very valuable companies that were
also going through the roof companies
like amc
blackberry nokia and then
robinhood which is the retail investing
app
stopped letting people buy the stocks
they just cut it off you could sell you
were allowed to sell
because selling helped all those
institutional investors but you couldn't
buy
and so you're you're if you're an actual
day trader if you're going in
you're really banking on this to make
money and it's not just some kind of
frivolous thing
what robin hood did was prevent your
ability to to make money and really
really could have cost you a lot of
money too
seemed totally unprecedented i mean
especially because you're talking about
the combination
of big tech this kind of retail
investing so the ceo of robinhood goes
on cnbc
cnbc anchors sitting there and says what
on earth are you please tell me
what's going on today and the ceo didn't
have a great answer
explain what happened today thank you
for having me on the show again
uh andrew um so what happened today
was as you pointed out we had to make a
very difficult decision it's been
uh it's been a challenging day we made
the decision
uh in the morning to limit the buying
of about 13 securities on our platform
so to be clear uh customers could still
sell
those securities if they had positions
in them
and they could also trade in the
thousands of other securities
on our platform so it was a difficult
decision
and and that's what we had to do as part
of normal operations
hold on wait hold on there i i was sort
of with you
until the end you said this was a very
difficult position a
very difficult decision rather and and
so therefore one might imagine it was a
sort of unusual position
that he was in and then at the end he
says but this was part of normal
operations
part of normal operations nothing about
what happened in the markets yesterday
was normal
and there is absolutely nothing normal
about telling your
customers that they can't buy the stocks
they want to buy and they can't buy the
positions in in the market that they
want to buy
of course not now the the word customer
here is a little interesting because
we all think of ourselves if you're
using a retail investing app you think
that you're the customer
but you're not the customer you're not
really paying for this sort of thing
who are the cut the customers are the
people within
the financial establishment and i love
i love his excuse he goes yep there were
13 assets that you weren't you weren't
allowed to buy positions in that was
very difficult
but you could buy positions and all the
other ones you know you couldn't buy
buy positions in the the assets where
you would have made money
but you could buy other stuff why can't
what's the big deal you could still buy
positions in assets that might lose you
money
just not the ones where you could have
made historic gains
no big deal right so this to the the guy
on the cnbc to his credit uh this was
not good enough so
uh hold up wait what uh come again but
explain then why did you do this
what did the sec call you and tell you
you had to do this
was there a problem inside the company
in terms of liquidity in terms of the
amount of deposits that you had
uh to to put in in front to the
exchanges what led to this
sure and let me let me explain exactly
how this works
um oh first of all i want to address
some of the misinformation that's been
out there because there's a lot of it
we absolutely did not do this at the
direction
of any market maker or hedge fund
uh or anyone we route to or other market
participants
the reason we did it was because uh
robinhood is a brokerage firm
we have lots of financial requirements
including
sec net capital requirements and
clearinghouse deposits
so that's money that we have to deposit
at various clearing houses
so some of these requirements uh
fluctuate quite a bit
based on volatility in the markets and
they can be substantial in the current
environment
okay fair enough so you know all of the
kind of financial jargon aside here
what he seems to be saying is yeah we we
needed
more money than we had we needed more
cash than we had on hand so you know we
had to shut this down but then the
interviewer goes on he says so this is a
liquidity issue
right this is just an issue you didn't
have enough cash and
and the ceo of robin hood says no no it
wasn't a liquidity issue no it's all
good it's all good it's not that it's
but we definitely didn't do it at the
behest of any institutional
investors or hedge funds or market
makers or people it was just
just normal normal operations and that's
why it was such a
difficult decision uh not
very convincing i don't know anything
about the inner workings of robin hood
and i don't know very much about the
financial services industry either
but i know that that answer did not
convince the guy on cnbc
and i don't think it convinced anyone
else either this
seems rigged it just seems rigged
it it it is something that uh
i think has been a long time coming for
people in politics because well i'm
getting a great deal of enjoyment out of
the craziness of the markets and how
funny this is and all the memes and
everything
there's a new one they they actually now
are running up the price of something
called dogecoin which is just a meme
it's like a fake cryptocurrency and they
ran that price up and now i think there
you're not even allowed to buy that now
all of this manipulation of the markets
this is forgetting us for a second the
the stocks themselves and the assets
themselves the right has needed a
reckoning on this for some time
we on the right love markets we love
free markets
we think free markets are a wonderful
tool for human flourishing
totally some people on the right however
have made an
idol out of free markets a free market
is not merely an
instrument to their broader political
ends the market has become the
end in and of itself and that is
ridiculous and sophomoric but also
just deeply deeply wrong because
and we've had this conversation with
regard to speech we'll have it now with
regard to markets
there is no such thing as a perfectly
free market
it doesn't exist just like there's no
such thing as perfectly free speech
there are always limits on it whether
it's limits on fraud or limits on
threats or limits on sedition or limits
on obscenity or limits on
this that or the other thing which has
have always existed in every single
society and always will
there is no such thing as the perfectly
free market there are constraints on the
market you saw this yesterday
sometimes we like to use the phrase of
adam smith we talk about the invisible
hand of the free market which to me is
sort of magical thinking
and there's some use of that that image
but
it's it's not you know a religious fact
and i think people have turned it into a
religious idol yesterday we did not see
the invisible hand of the free market we
saw the visible fist
of a rather unfree market
now i pointed this out and someone
actually had the audacity to say
yesterday
they responded they said the free market
part michael
is that you don't need to use robin hood
you you don't need to use robinhood a
so what you're really telling me is
build your own broker dealer you just
got through telling me
you just got through telling me that if
i don't like twitter i can build my own
twitter then we did build our own
twitter it was called parlor
and then they shut that one down too
they kicked it out of the app stores
then when that didn't work to totally
kill it they kicked it off of its web
services
whoopsie daisy build your own web
services build your own app store build
your own iphone
build your own domain registrar build
your own
internet build your own society that's
what they're saying here well build your
own broker dealer
well build your own stock exchange well
build your own securities and exchange
commission
well build your own government that's
what we're trying to do guys that's what
we're trying to do
and the way you do that is you engage in
politics but for
for so long the the market idolaters
have come in the people with this
extreme i don't even want to call it a
libertarian view because it's unfair to
libertarians but this kind of
shallow ridiculous talking point view
from the 90s and 2000s
that conservatives can never ever exert
political power that the people give us
because it would disturb my wonderful
cherished free market or something and
therefore we need to just
do nothing the only the only kind of
politics we can have is negative well
where did that get us where did that get
us now
even those very fundamentalists are
saying yeah build your own government
i i fully intend to do that i fully
intend
to get political power in
this country through political means
and get the people to elect good
candidates and then to exert that kind
of political power
against the rigged system that we are
seeing
we've seen it just in the last couple
days in the markets but we've seen it
much more broadly
over the past decades if you want to
be able to get a little historical
perspective on all this or financial
perspective or any kind of
perspective you got to check out great
courses with the great courses plus
you have unlimited access to thousands
of video and audio courses on hundreds
of fascinating topics
learn a new language discover what
einstein got wrong
even gain valuable insights into your
own public persona
there is something for everyone i
recommend you know me i don't want to do
anything practical
i want it all to just be kind of arcane
historical stuff
great course called 1066 the year that
changed everything
it's about the battle of hastings
sometimes i use this example
of one of my favorite tapestries the bio
tapestry shows bishop odo holding a club
beating up these dudes
and it says here bishop odo holding a
club comforts the boys
i think the word comfort meant something
different back then you can find out all
about
all these sorts of things not just the
battle of hastings so many other topics
too
i'm really glad to have found a more
productive way to spend my time
you can too get a free month of
unlimited access just visit my url
thegreatcoursesplus.com knowles that's a
whole
month to learn anything you want for
free sign up now
thegreatcoursesplus.com knowles
great course is a wonderful way to
educate yourself and to entertain
yourself uh and you can start it on your
phone you can finish it on your tv it's
just terrific
go check out the great courses
this robin hood ceo who was shutting
people out of
making investments yesterday but only
specific investments where they could
have made a lot of money
he is being sued as of course he should
be there is at least one class action
against him there's probably going to be
multiple
maybe they'll all converge brandon
nelson is a retail investor from
massachusetts filed a suit in the
southern district of new york
claiming that the company violated quote
the implied covenant of good faith and
fair dealing with its
customers when it restricted them from
making transactions on
high-yield assets quote honor about
january 27th
robin hood in order to slow the growth
of gamestop and
deprived their customers of the ability
to use their service abruptly
purposefully willfully and knowingly
pulled gamestop from their app meaning
retail investors could no longer buy or
even search for
gamestop on robinhood's app
good i'm glad i think this guy probably
committed
serious crimes not even just a breach of
contract for the users of robin hood
it seems like these were pretty serious
financial crimes that were committed
yesterday
that kind of market manipulation is
absurd whether or not he'll be held to
account for
for this i don't know because it just
seems like a rigged game right so it
seems like some people are held to
different standards than others
this is why i don't believe this whole
gamestop
dogecoin amc market thing i don't think
it's rich
versus poor i know there were some
conservative commentators yesterday who
were
afraid that we were delving into a kind
of rich versus poor
99 versus 1 kind of almost leftist
sounding dialogue about this
i don't think it's rich versus poor
first of all i don't think these
redditors
who drove the stock prices way up i
don't think they're poor i think they're
they're very intelligent obviously they
are fairly sophisticated they know how
to search for these kind of positions
that institutional investors have they
are smart enough to realize if if
someone's got a huge short position
and you can gather a million people or
two million people
to go in and pump up this asset then
you're going to
create a short squeeze and if you hold
on long enough then the asset's going to
go up unless there's market manipulation
from the outside
all of this to say these are not idiots
all right and
and one aspect of reddit and twitter
and social media that makes it difficult
to speak about this in a
in a sort of scientific data-driven
statistical way is people have anonymous
accounts right so you just you can't
you can't know that much about these
people if you're just trying to analyze
it from the outside
but in my own experience the plural of
anecdote will have to be data here in my
own experience
the the people i know who spend a lot of
time on reddit or twitter
and who have anonymous accounts are very
smart and they're not living in their
mom's basement and they're not waiting
to eat the chicken tendies or whatever
the memes say that they are
they're pretty urban people many of whom
have kind of normal jobs
who go to normal cocktail parties who
have a kind of
sophisticated yuppie-ish way of living
but who just realize how corrupt this
system is
right they they take this the same view
i was describing yesterday on the show
when we said is it about elitism or
populism i said when we have a good
elite i'm an elitist
when we have a corrupt elite i'm a
populist of course
i want to be governed by good wise
serious virtuous people
elites could be that and in that case
works for me
but when the elites are not that then
i'm i'm with buckley you know when he
says that i'd rather be governed by the
first 2000 people
in the boston phone book than the
faculty of harvard college bill buckley
was the same way he was an elitist
of sorts except when the elite was
totally decayed and degraded and debased
that's what i think this is about i
think
this is about an establishment
that comprises people who of all
different
looks of all different backgrounds of
all different economic
levels you know socioeconomic levels but
some people are in
some people are out it was funny too
because yesterday
a bunch of sort of socialists tried to
jump on the bandwagon and say oh yes
we're really showing it
we're showing it to this wall street
folks the people on reddit
they were not socialists they were not
antifa
they were not the dsa
they were the kinds of people who voted
for donald
trump and what the left believes is
that's just neo-nazis and white
supremacists or something but
it's not it's not it's it's people
of all levels of education and all
levels of whatever everything
else who realize that something about
this system
is rigged i know you're not allowed to
use that word when you discuss
elections or when you discuss the
administrative state or when you discuss
the financial establishment
but it just looks rigged i'll give you
give you an example
of this different set of rules for the
liberal elite we talked yesterday
briefly on the show about how
some dude on twitter i think he's 34
years old so at the time he was
if they somewhere in his 30s somewhere i
think at the time he was in his 20s
during 2015 2016 he had an anonymous
twitter account which was ricky vaughn
and it was very politically incorrect
and very offensive and you say all these
mean things he was just posting memes
and everything
he might go to prison for 10 years
because he posted a meme
which said hey if you're a democrat text
your vote
to this number and you can text your
vote and
then you don't need to worry about
voting and it's an old joke people have
done it for years it's the same joke as
saying
if you're a republican vote tuesday if
you're a democrat vote thursday right
and then you miss the vote
they're threatening him with 10 years in
prison for posting that meme meanwhile
a blue check mark on twitter someone
with the establishment
seal right somehow some of us
conservatives still
have kept it for now i still have my
blue check mark probably maybe not after
this episode i will
this woman christina wong who's some
comedian got the blue check
she posts the same
exact joke hey everybody this is
christina wong
and uh i'm coming out i'm a trump
supporter
and i just want to remind all my fellow
chinese americans for trump people of
color for trump
to vote vote for trump on wednesday
november 9th really important day we're
going to show this country
who's boss and that's our man donald
trump so don't forget to vote donald
trump
on november 9th
old joke right vote vote for trump the
day after the election i've made this
joke i was actually kicked off of
facebook for 24 hours on election day
for making this joke
five years ago four years ago
she also in her tweet about this wrote
uh text your vote to whatever the exact
same thing is ricky bond
she's still on twitter she's still out
of prison she's not being investigated
because she's a liberal she did exactly
100 exactly the same thing
as the guy behind ricky vaughn but ricky
vaughn is going to go to the can because
there's a different set of rules
for the liberal elite john kerry climate
czar under president biden
telling coal workers oil workers
natural gas workers that they are not
going to have their jobs
biden lied to them whoopsy daisy too bad
we've got a climate crisis
learn to make solar turbines wind
turbines
learn to learn to code right that's
that's
broadly what the the liberal
establishment tells
ordinary americans when they get rid of
their jobs
john kerry owns a private jet his family
owns a private jet john kerry gets to
fly all around the world however he
wants
he gets to use a whole lot more in terms
of
natural resources in terms of energy
it's to pollute a lot more than anybody
it doesn't matter is he's going to stop
you from polluting
and and really isn't that isn't that the
whole point
same could be said of al gore uses so
much more in the way of natural
resources leo dicaprio all the prominent
environmentalists
one set of rules for them one set of
rules
for you in a way
i'm i'm glad to see what happened
yesterday it's too bad because
some people lost a lot of money because
robin hood and it wasn't just robin hood
by the way when they say use a different
broker dealer
basically all of the broker dealers shut
out the ability to
buy positions in gamestop or amc or all
of these assets
so you couldn't do it and i'm i'm sorry
that people lost money because of this
sort of thing
but i am glad to see it i think we now
know what we're dealing with
all this talk all this silly talk that
republicans even had
duped themselves into believing we have
a perfectly free market
defend the hedge funds at all costs the
glorious wonderful hedge funds
wall street gives money to democrats
gives a lot of money to democrats
by many measures they give most of their
money to democrats
why am i supposed to defend these guys
hedge fund analysts are some of my best
friends i mean that since i actually
have a number of friends who are hedge
fund analysts
however i don't think there's anything
special about hedge fund analysts as a
class or hedge fund managers as a class
that means i need to defend them if they
do good things that's good i'll defend
them
if they do bad things i won't and if
they if they
support liberal candidates and even
liberal republicans when they do support
a republican
why do i need to defend them why why do
we need to carry water for people
who hate us who hate our views who won't
let us participate in society
and who have no particular loyalty to
our country
or our traditions this is why
conservatives like to invest
in physical assets like gold and you've
got to go check out acre gold
man what a great segue the price of gold
has been skyrocketing
lately now there is a new way to buy
gold through a company called acre
acre lets you subscribe to gold bars for
as little as 30
a month you pay each month once your
gold stash reaches the price of their
gold bars they ship
discreetly acre gold to your house
acre lets you invest in physical gold
without coming out of pocket all at once
the way that this happens because
obviously bar gold costs a lot of money
you pay into it you pay into it you pay
into it once you
reach the price of the bar of gold they
ship it to you
they've recently introduced their new
hundred dollar per month subscription
for their five gram gold bar
if the last few days have not convinced
you
that having some of your investment in
physical precious metals
might be a good idea with all the crazy
market stuff i don't know what we'll
convince you
get acre gold dot com slash knowles
start
investing in physical gold today make
sure you go to getacregold.com
knowles acres giving away a gold bar to
qualify
tweet or post why you should be the
recipient and tag
at get underscore acre that is
getakergold.com knowles and thank you
aker gold for supporting this show
i have a play for you in three acts
this tells you a lot about the situation
that conservatives find themselves in in
the country
yesterday aoc tweets out about the whole
gamestop thing and the markets and
everything she tweets out quote
this is unacceptable we need to know
more about robin hood's decision to
block retail investors from purchasing
stock while hedge funds are freely able
to trade the stock as they see fit
as a member of the financial services
committee i'd support a hearing if
necessary
so i read that and i say wow i have
common ground with aoc
okay works for me ted cruz
our pal you know senator cruz who uh
we'll be talking with on verdict very
shortly probably about this he responds
he says
fully agree aoc responds quote
i'm happy to work with republicans on
this issue where there's common ground
but you almost had me murdered three
weeks ago so you can sit this one out
happy to work with almost any other gop
that aren't trying to get me
killed in the meantime if you want to
help you can resign
i give senator cruz a lot of credit
for engaging in good faith trying to
reach out
to somebody like aoc find some common
ground
they're not interested they're not
interested
clearly i'm glad he tried i'm glad he
tried
shows that we we are trying and they are
not
but now we've learned a lesson there too
first of all i like how aoc says well
i'm willing to work with any republican
but not ted cruz
and not donald trump and not this one
and not that one and no republican she
doesn't think
any republican is legitimate
he almost had me killed uh what what is
your evidence for that oh of course you
don't have any
doesn't matter they
hate us on the left they have been
saying for months now that we are
all nazis and white supremacists
who should be kicked off of twitter
who should be kicked out of our jobs who
should be kicked
out of our schools who should be kicked
off of our investing apps
who should be kicked out of our banks
who should be ostracized utterly
from society and conservatives
we do this thing where we try to win
their respect
we're not going to we try to do this
thing where we try to prove we're not
racist
we're not going to it's not going to
work
aoc is going to do what aoc wants to do
the left is going to do what what the
left wants to do they are not
going to try to work with republicans in
any way
they are going to follow the science
the science of progressivism dr fauci
what a wonderful guy dr fauci our true
leader he uh he just came out
he said if you if you get the vaccine
which you soon will probably have to do
if you get the vaccine that's not a free
pass to travel
it is not a good idea to travel
period i mean if you absolutely have to
travel and it's essential
then obviously one would have to do that
but we don't want people to
think because they got vaccinated then
other public health
recommendations just don't apply one of
the biggest
things that are really not well
understood is people
ask why should i even have to wear a
mask
after i get my second shot and the
reason is
very clear that the primary endpoint of
the vaccine trial
was clinically apparent infection so you
could conceivably
get infected get no symptoms and still
have virus
in your nasal pharynx which means that
you would have to wear a mask
to prevent you from infecting someone
else as well as
the other side of the coin where you may
not be totally
protected yourself so getting vaccinated
does not say now i have a free pass to
travel
yeah look just just because you do all
the stuff that we're telling you to do
even though sometimes it contradicts
our previous advice day by day just
because you do that doesn't mean you
have a free pass to travel
you know travel what all of us in the
establishment
have often called a human right travel
a constitutional right that you have to
move freely
yeah you don't have a free pass to do
that anymore because of science
joe biden made this point the other day
he tweeted out
science will always guide my
administration
he capitalized administration in a weird
way you know they always made fun of
trump for weird capitalizations
he does that too he probably
intentionally would capitalize science
though even if it didn't begin a
sentence
because he's referring to science as a
sort of god
science will guide my administration
what he means by science here obviously
is not
what we think of as a science the system
of material
inquiry and empiricism and observation
to lead us to
new knowledge about the physical world
he's not referring to that i mean
they've contradicted themselves
sometimes by the hour
he's referring to science in a political
way which the the left has done for
years and years in the same way that
marx would refer to science and marxists
would refer to the science of politics
or the science of history
the new left would would refer to these
sorts of terms in the mid-20th century
this is why aoc is not going to work
with ted cruz and not going to work with
any other republican
they are on the right side of history
they know the science of history they
know the science of politics
and for the uninitiated
that those sorts of unwashed people can
be of no help
gotta you just gotta get rid of them aoc
is gonna be fine on her own
you know we on the right we often point
out the hypocrisy of the left that's
probably what we spend most of our time
doing
so so much for the tolerant left so much
for healing and unity
so much for this so much for that as
though
in this sort of innocent naive hope we
think that
one day the left is going to realize oh
my goodness we're not being tolerant
you're right
oh my goodness we're not being
particularly unifying not trying to heal
the country
they know they know that they're not
they don't want to tolerate us they've
written essays
famous essays called repressive
tolerance for instance
about why they don't want to tolerate us
they don't want to unite with us they
don't want to heal
they want to heal the country by getting
rid of us by ostracizing us
and they're doing a good job of it
and because we're so afraid of ever
using political power
they succeed even when we win even when
republicans win elections even when we
had unified government
from 2017 to 2019
what did we do what did we do as a
matter of real
sweeping legislative change we passed a
tax cut because
we are beholden to a shallow silly idea
that pretty much just became the
boilerplate conservative talking point
in the 90s and 2000s
that we can never exercise political
power
we have to we have to respect the free
market we need to live in holy fear of
the free market
what free market what free market
market doesn't look very free to me we
can never
suggest that the left moderate their
language moderate their behavior because
of free speech the idol of
what free speech i don't see free speech
doesn't look very free from from my
vantage
looks like it's full of a censorship
regime
from the left and even when we look back
further
before say the 60s and into the maybe
the 50s or the 40s
even then when conservatives had much
much better hold on the culture
we did we had a free speech regime in
the american tradition of free speech
we also had mccarthyism we had tough
laws against obscenity we had
all sorts of rules about speech we had
we had just a different set of standards
right we had the traditional
conservative standards we've convinced
ourselves to abandon that
we've convinced ourselves to abandon
financial standards
because of a shallow ideology that
ironically the left forced it on us
during the mid 20th century to convince
us to stop exercising power
and so we we appear to be impotent
and the the game appears to be rigged
we started to wake up to that in 2016.
how much longer
is it going to take before we realize
the the real nature of this system
the real nature of our elites and for us
to begin to exercise our political power
to push back
one way we do that in the culture is by
releasing our movies we just had our
first movie come out here at the daily
wire
run hide fight it's exclusive for daily
wire members
the elite critics hate it they gave it
like a two percent or something on
rotten tomatoes
the audience loves it they gave it a 93
with thousands of reviews
you can watch run hide fight on
streaming apps at apple tv
roku if you're not a daily wire member
use promo code rhf to get 25
off that is rhf for 25
off
now my favorite time of the week we get
to the mailbag from matt
michael with president biden's first 100
hours under his
belt who would you say is the worst
president of the united states
joe biden fdr or woodrow wilson
uh woodrow wilson is the worst because
he was the smartest about it
woodrow wilson understood
uh what he was doing you can read i
think the essay is called what is
progress
something like that what is progressive
i think it's what is progress and
woodrow wilson lays it all out he says
look i'm a political scientist
i'm taking these ideas that came to us
from europe and their very recent ideas
and i've been working on them in the
academy and i'm going to use those ideas
to overturn
the old constitutional system which is
now outdated
and it's according to an old theory of
science and i'm going to replace
the old theory of science was newton
fixed laws to the universe
i'm going to replace it with the new
darwinian theory of science which is
evolution there's no such thing as fixed
permanent laws there's no such thing as
fixed permanent human nature on which
our constitutional system was based
so we're going to have a new
administrative state we're going to take
the power
the political power away from people and
give it to these experts these genius
elites who are going to govern us and
we're going to have a wonderful country
that way
now fdr in many ways implemented the
wilson plan
but wilson was the kind of mad genius
behind it
and the cause of many many problems from
alex
dear michael i'm a student at the
university of florida i live on campus
in the dorms it is current university
policy
that unless i'm in my room showering
brushing my teeth or eating i have to
wear a mask at all times
i've not been following these rules up
to this point and no one has said
anything to me
this all changed today when my floor ra
sent out a group message
saying that some of the residents had
not been following the guidelines and
that he was going to
start being really strict and issuing
reports on violators as i am the only
one on the floor who i've ever seen not
wearing a mask
i assume this is directed at me should i
just shut up and wear the mask
or is there a way to continue my protest
without risking my housing contract
yeah you seem to be in the position that
conservatives find themselves in
so i'm the sort of aspirational advice
i'll give you is say
you know take that mask off and stand up
but you'll probably lose your housing if
you do that so if you're willing to do
that fine you live off campus or
something
but the political reality that you're in
is you have no leverage
you have no leverage because the
school is well it's obviously run by the
state government
it uh so if if the good guys don't run
the state government you're in trouble
now we do it ron desantis is down there
that's pretty good
but the blob the the bureaucracy of that
state i presume is not quite as
conservative as
governor desantis we have lost control
more broadly over education that's been
given away we've lost control over the
narrative on the masks and the virus
that's been given away
we don't have a way to exercise power
and because of that
you're vulnerable so probably what you
got to do it's the same thing when i go
on an airplane all i want to do is rip
off that stupid mask
i will be put on the no-fly list i won't
be able to fly anywhere
so i hate wearing the stupid mask i
never wear it
practically when i'm out and about in my
daily life but when i'm on the airplane
because we don't have any power
they force us to you've got to be
wise as a serpent innocent is a dove
right you've got to be clever and beyond
that
you've got to amass some power and
influence and be able to use it
we're in a position right now where you
probably can't do that
but it's worth as you form your
political views which happens
especially in college it's worth
remembering this situation and taking
some lessons from it
from matthew michael do you think there
will be any politicians registering
switching rather from democrat to
republican in the next year or two prior
to 2022
it seems that tulsi gabbard is making
the rounds on fox not that fox is
entirely conservative anymore and joe
manchin seems to
not completely fall in line with his
fellow leftists
uh with ending the filibuster or these
the sign of a red wave
i don't know i mean tulsi has been
saying some good things and joe
manchin's always been a little more
moderate anyway
usually not when it counts but at least
in the way he talks
what it's a sign of is that these people
know their constituents
chelsea gabbard knows that the people
who are listening to her
are common sense people
they're not uniformly republican or
conservative by any means but they're
they're not buying into the kind of
established
liberal secular religion i guess the
same would go for joe manchin
west virginia you can't be aoc aoc is
not getting elected to anything in west
virginia
so that's good but i don't know maybe
they'll switch parties maybe that
probably probably joe manchin won't
maybe chelsea gabbard will
however i don't even think
that what we're looking at over the next
few years
is is about that i don't think it's
about new people registering or whatever
there's going to be a permanent wall
around the capitol
you know it's so funny that the left
calls us all fascists
and yet they wouldn't invite any of the
people to their inauguration for the
president who supposedly got the most
votes of any president in human history
that they now have a standing army in
washington d.c
to keep the people away from them it's a
little weird isn't it
they've now taken away election
integrity measures
notably in pennsylvania where they had
to violate the state constitution to do
it but
virtually everywhere else too where now
we have
unsolicited widespread mailings we now
have election month instead of election
day no no voter id measures in a lot of
places
so sure i mean i hope democrats become
republicans
but republicans don't have any sway we
don't have any power
so it doesn't matter if 90 of the
country becomes republicans
if we can't rely on election integrity
measures
it's still going to be a big uphill
battle from alex
in your last two shows you mentioned
that the family is the fundamental
social building block
however i thought that the virtuous
individual was intended to be the
fundamental building block of a
successful society
for example our justice system is
intended to operate on individuals
our economy is based on the principle of
mutually consenting transactions between
individuals
to a degree success in various
hierarchies such as career church
positions and even dating is intended to
be based on
individual competency and merit could
you please clarify how these ideas are
consistent with your claim about the
family
i realize this may be a which came first
the chicken or the egg type questions
sure i mean i some of these claim these
assertions that you're making i think
are somewhat dubious
i appreciate the zeal with which you're
asserting them but you're you're not
providing a lot of evidence and
obviously you don't have a ton of room
to do that
in a mailbag question but i think there
are many of these sorts of things that
that we're so used to asserting as
talking points
but perhaps when we think about them
it's it's difficult to explain how
the the reason that we have this idea
that the individual
is the fundamental unit of society
and that maximizing individual autonomy
is the be all and end all of society
is because we've been fed a bunch of
lies
mostly by the left actually over the
last half century
but that that view is not the
traditional american view
obviously good old individual effort and
gumption is very important and nobody
denies that but
that's not what i'm talking about what
i'm talking about is a sort of
anthropology
what i'm talking about is where does
society come from
when when we craft societies as
societies develop
do they develop out of atomized
individuals who spring into existence
from the thin air and then drop down in
the middle of a forest
and sort of educate themselves on their
own and come to their own ideas on their
own maybe they're
inbred ideas and then they walk up to
one another and they say okay
we're all total individuals and we're
gonna form a society on a social compact
and and we all agree to it by mutual
consent and that's it
is that how society is formed no and
then what happens for the next
generation do they
they pop out of thin air too no that
isn't what happens is
we're born through no decision of our
own
we're born into a family and into a
society a community and into a broader
society
and we are educated in that society and
specifically by that family
we take on the customs and traditions
and views of that society
and we contribute to it because we are
individuals and we do have free will
but the social conditions also shape our
our desires also shape our will
form our habits which are the virtues
right
virtues are habits they're not just
things we arrive at through
thin air out of thin air through our own
reason alone
and as a result these institutions
really really matter
that's that's how things happen in real
life now i understand
in philosophy class particularly if
you're talking about liberal philosophy
class
things happen differently but i i there
is some
utility to that when we're thinking
through our politics
but i think we've gone so far in that
fantasy ideological direction we're not
looking at
the way things actually work in front of
us and this all redounds to the left's
benefit
because the left is always trying to
destroy these institutions to destroy
the family because
when you're talking about a leftist
revolutionary political movement
going up against traditional ordered
settled
society with lots of different
subsidiary institutions at every level
down to the family all the way up to
national
institutions it's very difficult for the
revolutionary
movement to come in and overturn all of
that it's just the society is so strong
but when the revolutionary movement
comes in and all those mediating
institutions have been destroyed
and it's just a bunch of disconnected
individuals who are extraordinarily
skeptical of one another distrustful of
one another who have nothing in common
it's much much easier to take over and
that's that's what the left is banking
on and that's what that's what i'm
trying to say when i'm
describing this dichotomy between the
family and the individual as the basic
unit
from hayden dear mr knowles i agree that
the 20
bill should be left alone but you said
something that peaked my interest
someone said to you that jackson should
be disqualified due to the trail of
tears
to which you said martin van buren
should be kept off our currency
in school we were taught that jackson is
to blame what what do you believe is to
blame for the trail of tears well it
just it happened on van buren's watch
so it's just chronologically it doesn't
doesn't work to
blame it all on jackson the reason they
blame jackson and the reason that they
they you know don't like him and they
castigate him and they
find him to be an easy target is because
he did embrace a policy of indian
removal
he fought in the indian wars let's not
forget the the way that
that the europeans got this territory is
in part by forming alliances with indian
groups like the pilgrims did
it was in part through trade purchasing
land
fair and square and it was in part
through war
and by the way the way that various
indian groups got territory is by going
to war with other indian groups
and by the way the way that people get
land throughout history
often is through war or through trade so
it's all the ways that we did here
but because the left hates this country
the left goes in and says the land was
the indians
any way that we got it was illegitimate
and andrew jackson was clear about this
and the fact that andrew jackson even
supported a policy
that would remove some indians from the
american land and put them in different
land
is uh reason enough to erase him from
our memory
now the question that naturally follows
when
when someone says that we need to give
the land back to the indians is which
indians do we give them to the comanche
i guess we took land from the comanche
but maybe we should give it back to the
apache because the comanche took the
land from the apache
do are we going to give land our
interests in latin america we're going
to give it back to the aztecs
we're gonna give it back to the people
that the aztecs conquered is there even
a way to distinguish at this point after
all these years
probably probably not
next question from jaden before i have
to go michael what is your opinion on
evolution
matt walsh said he believes in it but
i've never heard what you think
uh thanks uh i don't think about it very
much i don't really care
it's not a you know i just i don't care
that much about
various other niche fields of
physical science uh there seemed to be
some problems with darwin
this was uh well laid out by david
berlinski david gallernter a genius
computer scientist said that the
problems with darwin he found them to be
sort of
darwin's theories to be mathematically
impossible so he's moved away from them
but i don't know you know i'm just not
expert enough in in darwin or or lamarck
who has sort of had something of a
resurgence i guess through neolamarcism
and
epigenetics it's all interesting enough
to me i i'm
open-minded about it but it doesn't
doesn't particularly affect my
view of the world all right that's the
show i'll see you next week i'm michael
knowles that's the michael knowles show
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer
jeremy boary our technical director is
austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
production manager pavel vadofsky editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coramina
hair and makeup by nikka geneva and
production coordinator mckenna waters
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire
2021 hey everybody this is andrew clavin
host of the andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching
and the moons turn to blood but on the
andrew clavin show that's where the fun
just gets started so come on over to the
andrew clavin show and laugh your way
through the fall of the republic with me
andrew clavin